[Music]
on this Saturday night Lee leaves
thousands in the dark
the post-tropical Cyclone swirls to the
maritimes as a wild weather down here
it's plan of action we're live on the
ground
the nightmare to coordinate help in
Libya our interview with a Libyan
champion of women's rights on the sad
reality for women and children there
right now
pile up at the plant and that's what
we're looking for our fair share what an
ongoing Auto strike in the U.S could
mean for your wallet as concerns over
labor talks grow here at home
and woman life Freedom
marking the one-year anniversary of a
global movement that still rages on
global national with paranasa
whipping waves and fierce winds is
post-tropical Cyclone Lee makes landfall
in the maritimes battering and soaking
Nova Scotia and New Brunswick with heavy
rains and high winds some areas are
recording gusts of up to 110 kilometers
per hour
good evening to you thanks for joining
us now even if it isn't that monster
category one hurricane it was just days
ago officials are warning not to
underestimate Lee the post-tropical
Cyclone has left tens of thousands of
people without electricity between Nova
Scotia and New Brunswick Callum Smith
starts off our coverage tonight
the always popular Peggy's Cove
continued bringing people out in droves
today catching a glimpse of the stormy
seas and Wild Waves near the iconic
Lighthouse and a lone security guard
left trying to keep people back
in nearby Prospect Nova Scotia the
Breakwater doing its best to fend off
the waves with homes and people nearby
the wild weather down here the tight The
Surge is up and everything is Tip Top
high
some 200 000 customers were Off the Grid
in Nova Scotia and New Brunswick this
afternoon leaving Crews tasked with
their pairs trying to get people back on
more than sixty thousand were bumped off
at in Halifax alone in these homeowners
front yard we thought that would be the
worst thing that we lost power it turns
out now a tree toppled over around
lunchtime no clear damage but they're
worried about the weight on their home
other than a few downed trees it seemed
fairly quiet and Halifax aside from
those waves this is power for the course
yeah yeah we get everything here we're
fired as you can get people in shadiak
New Brunswick perhaps enjoyed that surf
a little too much Saturday morning we're
gonna stay close to Shore and really uh
we're all experienced Riders
so beginners are definitely not
encouraged to come on a day like today
in Moncton a maritime storm didn't even
stop this wedding from taking place
officials have said Lee wouldn't be as
bad as when post tropical storm Fiona
hit last year but for many it's still
packed a significant punch this is the
first one I don't know in my whole life
that I've seen the storm like this this
looks much worse than Fiona we didn't
get the storm surge like that well the
region may have avoided the worst damage
has been done and it will take some time
until the full extent of that can be
assessed Callum Smith Global News
Halifax
and there's still plenty to remain
cautious about as the storm moves
through the region Global chief
meteorologist Anthony Farnell is in
Yarmouth Nova Scotia experiencing some
of the harsh weather firsthand Anthony
what's it being like over there today
what have you seen
well I've seen just about everything
that you would expect in a hurricane now
post-tropical Cyclone Lee we woke up and
it was pouring rain they've had about 75
millimeters of water here in Yarmouth
and that is on top of what's been a very
wet summer although flooding was not the
primary concern today it really was the
surf the waves crashing ashore the fact
that the storm surge if it arrived right
at high tide would have been very bad
and likely inundated a lot of the
boardwalks and a lot of the roads around
some of the coves but the wind the
widespread nature of it and the fact
that pockets of damage occurred in just
about every community of Nova Scotia and
into New Brunswick that really is what's
going to have the lasting memory the
fact that these trees came down on power
lines and affected just people's way of
life and it's going to take some time
obviously for the power to come back on
but as we were going around just the
region around Yarmouth just seeing the
surf is just an incredible sight and the
fact that the wind has completely done
the full spectrum 360 Degrees from when
we got up this morning and until now as
the eye or what was left of it the
center of Lee passed just off yarmouth's
shore and actually made landfall not too
long ago in Long Island Nova Scotia now
it's moving across the Bay of Fundy
Farah
I mean it is moving its way through
Atlanta Canada so what kind of
conditions can we expect into Sunday is
it still a threat
yeah it's still a threat throughout the
night tonight and one thing it is
starting to get dark here in Nova Scotia
and there are power lines down all over
the place there are trees down as well
so obviously you're not supposed to go
out at night you just got to wait till
tomorrow and you'll be able to start the
cleanup but the storm is moving now a
bit quicker let's take a look at the big
picture the fact that these tropical
storm force winds extend over 600
kilometers across all that heavy rain
still falling in New Brunswick but the
track brings it across that province
into the Gulf of St Lawrence and then
over Newfoundland and Labrador but it
will be weakening quickly over these
colder Waters and now that it's
post-tropical it means that it's going
to even more so we can and then move
back out into the Atlantic so tomorrow
is a much better day with lighter winds
tonight however still more damage could
occur pharah okay that's good to know
thanks so much Global News meteorologist
Anthony Farnell in Yarmouth Nova Scotia
residents of Hay River Northwest
Territories are finally able to go back
home after being displaced by wildfires
for more than a month today the
evacuation order for the town was
downgraded to an evacuation alert
residents though are being warned that
health services will be limited and
schools won't open right away
in Calgary six more day cares have
closed linked to that massive E coli
outbreak there Alberta's chief medical
officer says children from the sites
have tested positive some linked to
daycares from the original outbreak so
far there have been 337 lab confirmed
cases 12 children are in hospital six of
them are on dialysis
in Northeast Libya search and rescue
efforts for those who went missing from
the devastating floods in derna are now
into a sixth day with more bodies being
pulled from the sea according to the red
crescent more than 11 000 people had
been killed so far with an estimated ten
thousand people still missing entire
districts of the coastal city were swept
away or buried in brown mud after two
dams broke sending a wall of water
gushing through the streets the United
Nation says more than one thousand
people have been buried in Mass Graves
prompting warnings from Aid groups about
the risk of contaminating water
joining us now is Libyan Canadian Dr
Allah murabit founder of the voice of
Libyan women and a global expert in
health sustainability development and
women's rights Dr Robert thanks so much
for joining us I know this is a very
difficult time for your community
thanks so much for having me but I I
really appreciate all the work that you
and Global are doing to amplify what's
happened in Libya I know you've been in
touch just recently with uh what's going
on on the ground with people on the
ground there what are you hearing
um I'm hearing that it's I think one of
the realities of this flood was that it
happened in a country that was already
riddled with you know conflict and poor
governance
um and so I'm hearing what's expected
after five days that rebuilding is
unlikely to happen soon
um that this will heavily impact you
know children and families and and for
for years and decades to come and and I
think what I'm hearing more than
anything is just how much this
highlights the vulnerability of this
region to climate change and especially
when you marry that to human negligence
uh to government corruption Decades of
dictatorship and conflict and really the
erosion of governance
um there's a lot of confusion on the
ground I don't think anybody expected a
catastrophe of this scale
um so despite the fact that we have a
lot of international organizations
coming in we have a lot of national
Goodwill and people coming into the
region to help as much as they can it's
incredibly disorganized people are
incredibly confused about where to go
for basic resources
um where to go for shelter for food so
so just a lot of confusion
um heartbreak and I think anger I think
a lot of anger
oh I'll bet there's anger there and
there's frustration and uh that's not
even talking about the mental toll that
people have gone through now you mean a
champion of women's rights in Libya but
you know I've noticed there's very few
images of women there and we're hearing
very few female voices from derna so
what are you hearing about what the
women are going through their plight
there right now
I think for a lot of the women a lot of
the women are as surprised by as taken
aback by the catastrophe a lot of them
are continuing to look for family a lot
of them are continuing to to look for
shelter and food and loved ones I think
one thing that makes
um crisis much more difficult uh is
separation from family during an
emergency makes you know women and girls
especially vulnerable to abuse because
of their gender their age and and their
Reliance on others for assistance for
safe passage for resources
um and so there's definitely a
heightened vulnerability there that we
all have to be conscious of that happens
in all crises not just in Libya and
that's something that I know many
International organizations are are
keeping in mind but but one that we all
should
Dr olama rabbit thank you so much for
your time and your Insight
thank you so much for having me butter
Auto Workers in the U.S walk off the job
coming up how unprecedented strike
action could impact Canada
unprecedented labor action in the U.S
Auto Workers targeting the big three
American Auto companies have hit the
picket lines all at the same time as
Richard zusman tells us Canadians could
be impacted next
it's a labor traffic jam the likes the
auto sector has never seen simultaneous
strikes happening at General Motors Ford
and Chrysler's parent company stalantis
for the first time ever this strategy
will keep the companies guessing
it will give our national negotiators
maximum leverage and flexibility and
bargaining for now three assembly plants
in the United States are behind picket
lines with the United Auto Workers and
the auto makers back at the negotiating
table the union demanding a bigger share
of record profits shorter work weeks and
stronger job security in the wake of
shifts to electric vehicles we've gone
years without a raise you know we want
our fair share
and this may just be the start of the
pile up here in Canada Auto Union unifor
and Ford are negotiating the union so
far rejecting two offers from the
company with a midnight Eastern strike
deadline approaching on Monday we are
also experiencing a once in a century
transition of the sector in this context
Auto Workers across Canada are seeking a
fair contract and we've started with
Ford Motor Company
of ongoing American job action has been
minimal in Canada so far but any
extended strike will put a dent in an
industry that currently sees more than
35 billion dollars of goods shipped over
the border every year Canada is going to
escape without too much damage unless
the United Auto Workers decide to expand
the scope of their strike and then all
bets are off it's a potential impact the
supply of Parts which could end up
driving up costs Richard zusman Global
News prime minister Justin Trudeau
announced several measures this week to
address the cost of living crisis in
Canada at the end of his party's caucus
Retreat the new measures include several
ways to tackle the housing crisis but
the question is will they actually make
a difference Mercedes Stevenson returns
with a new season off the West block and
joins us now to answer that question
Mercedes
for our prime minister Justin Trudeau
announced in London that the Liberals
are finally following through on a
promise they first made in the 2015
election to remove the GST on the
construction of new apartment buildings
we spoke with two big City Mayors to
find out if these measures will make a
difference for Canadians looking for a
new home the bottom line Mayors say all
three levels of government need to work
together the idea of blaming one level
of government or another does not get
more units in the ground quicker what
gets more units in the ground quicker is
collaborating talking designing programs
at all levels of government that
actually cause us to work together and
create the conditions for putting many
units in the ground and not just general
units but the kinds of housing we need
Calgary's mayor says a strong economy
and influx of international students and
people coming from abroad including
those escaping War zones like Ukraine
means that the housing crisis is only
getting worse it's really sort of The
Perfect Storm we started to see people
in positions of vulnerability when it
came to housing especially glaringly
during covid and since then we've been
taking in a lot more people over 60
individuals a day if you break down the
math and we just can't keep Pace
conservative leader Pierre pauliev
blames the housing crisis on Trudeau and
says he will introduce his own plan to
get homes built when Parliament
reconvenes on Monday pharah Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thank you Mercedes
and you can watch the full interviews
tomorrow on the season premiere of the
West block right here on global
[Music]
navigating landmines on the front lines
ahead how moscow's mines are impacting
Ukraine's counter-offensive
in Ukraine the country's government says
one of the biggest factors affecting the
speed if it's counter-offensive is the
density of land mines across its
enormous front line by some estimates
it's going to take years or even decades
to completely remove all the land mines
in the country in the meantime
ukrainians are getting creative in those
efforts Redmond Shannon reports
a painstaking and deadly job The soppers
Who clear Minds in Ukraine are nicknamed
hedgehogs by their comrades
sometimes wearing these Canadian
designed spider boots for protection
Ukraine has laid its own minds too but
the majority are Russian
moscow's minds are defending hundreds of
kilometers of Front Line in some places
they are up to 16 kilometers Deep by
some estimates across Ukraine an area
twice the size of the maritimes is now
contaminated by mines
even after the counter-offensive and the
war is over it will likely Take Years or
even decades to clear all the mines
President Vladimir zielinski has
appealed to allies for more expertise
and equipment
in the meantime some ukrainians have
taken matters into their own hands like
engineer Vitale
when these chains rotate they can hit
the ground with a force of one ton
detonating any mine
he has designed a mind flail machine
from a regular excavator and is now
testing it with the Army
we calculated that it destroys 100 of
Mines but if that doesn't prove to be
the case this huge machine can be
controlled remotely to check how its
tracks hold up driving over large mines
machines like this would be sitting
docks on the front line so would only be
used on recaptured land
meaning the work of fearless soppers
will be crucial to any advances Ukraine
makes on the battlefield day after day
inch by inch many of them have died and
will die sacrificing their own future
for that of Ukraine Redmond Channel and
Global News London
next woman life Freedom the global
movement that still rages on one year
after the death of Masa ameni
[Music]
we begin with a pair of deadly Mysteries
what's going on this is insane we really
really believed that it was likely that
this was a kidnapping once the case goes
cold it just goes in a box I want to
tell my life that caused the pears on my
arms to stand I saw my dad just like
hanging and bleeding hard and I heard
Papa and I said father God my kids have
been shot what was the motive hate she
never had a chance watch crime beat
every Friday and Sunday night all summer
on global
the newscast that's more than just the
news of the day access to Lahaina
byground has been largely limited to
Emergency Operations covering and
uncovering stories that matter this is a
war that's still being fought and
they're adding photographs of Fallen
Soldiers global national with Donna
freezing in the end it was the new
buildings that crumbled the old
buildings are still standing winner of
the 2023 Canadian screen Award for best
national news anchor and best national
newscast in Iran today security forces
have released Masa ameny's father after
briefly detaining him and warning him
not to Mark the anniversary of his
daughter's death
emini's death in police custody one year
ago Unleashed months of anti-government
protests that spiraled into the biggest
show of opposition to the authorities in
years one year later Masa amini's Legacy
is still being felt in Iran and around
the world reports
[Applause]
the chance that defined Iran after the
death of Masa Gina amini woman life
Freedom
Canadians joining those around the world
today showing their support for the
people of Iran in their fight against
the regime demonstrators say they're
here to amplify calls for freedom and
Justice they've lived in fear even from
Far because all of us we have our family
stay in Iran but now we're Gathering to
to make things happen
what started out as grief and anger over
Masa amini's death quickly turned into a
rallying cry that echoed through some of
Iran's biggest protests and decades
the 22 year old Kurdish Iranian woman
died while under the Detention of the
country's so-called morality police last
year after being accused of not wearing
her hijab properly
[Music]
demonstrators say amini has turned into
a symbol with demonstrations evolving
over the past 12 months saying now it's
about everyone and everything in Iran
because of this solidarity of the whole
globe behind us that's why we can do it
that's why this time is completely
different many Iranian women in an act
of defiance are refusing to wear the
compulsory hijab no matter what the
consequences video surfacing online show
a much different country than before
amini's death
this woman reportedly fighting back
after a cab driver demanded she cover
her hair
since the Nationwide Uprising started
last year the atrocities in Iran are
mounting five protesters linked to the
movement had been hanged more than 500
demonstrators killed dozens of them
children
and hundreds of school girls choking
coughing falling ill after apparent
chemical attacks
demonstrators in Vancouver say the fight
is not over and they will keep up with
weekly Saturday rallies to support
Iranians who they say just want to have
a normal life nagar moshehdi Global News
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight tonight's your
Canada is the Masa Gina amini street
sign in Ottawa paying tribute to the 22
year old the city installed this sign in
June in front of the former side of the
Iranian embassy it's going to stay there
for a year then it'll be moved to City
Hall
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other
good night
[Music]